first event of its kind the
international Casino and Resort canine
trials and they're putting handlers and
canines to the tests that's right Mary
Jane belieso takes us to Henderson with
how handlers are competing to win but
also how they're keeping tourists safe
it's the first International Casino and
Resort canine trials here in Las Vegas
at the event handlers and their canines
demonstrate their skills to be ranked as
the best in various categories so that's
really what this organization is for and
what today's event is is to bring all
these teams together so we can all meet
together we're gonna give you six
minutes Ryan Milburn is the president of
the international Casino and Resort
working dog Association and organizer
for this event but when we can
collaborate uh training AIDS instructors
all that stuff training areas it really
Rises it raises the capabilities of all
the dogs in the city training exercises
and classes replicate basic Patrol bed
bug firearm or explosive detection
scenarios handlers face every day
Rocky mugbuwal is a canine Officer
working alongside rocket an
eight-year-old yellow lab combing the
area for a silent but serious threat bed
bugs we can pick out the actual location
of the where it's infested versus they
fumigate the whole house bed bug
detection is now becoming part of their
routine inspection to keep infestations
in hotels at Bay we train them to
actually find that particular odor which
is bed bugs so it could be the eggs the
actual lives and dead and also their uh
droppings the dogs are rewarded with
points and lots of effects during this
competition with handlers receiving
award plaques at the end of the event
Milburn says at the end of the day it's
all about supporting Dog Handlers all
over the world there's a lot of hard
work that goes into making sure that dog
is the tip of the spear and the best
they can be to detect those things that
can hurt our guests and our co-workers
it's a fun collaborative thing but it's
also keeping all these teams on their
toes and really driving that training
while this event is all about friendly
competition it all comes down to
elevating safety for employees and the
public Mary Jane bellezza 8 News Now
very interesting all right over 100
people from Across the Nation signed up
for this private event and organizers
are hoping to host a bigger event next
year